[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halallweg guten Abend ihnen
allen an diesem Wahlsonntag der
überschattet ist vom Krieg in
Israel Kriegszustand nach Terrorangriff
der Hamas Israel greift 800 Ziele im
Gazastreifen an als 100 Menschen sind
von der Hamas entführt
worden doppelte Landtagswahlen in Hessen
gewinnt die Union deutlich dazu in
Bayern bleibt sie starkste Kraft die AFD
schafft es vermutlich in beiden Ländern
auf Platz
2 und Verzweiflung im afghanischen
Erdbebengebiet mehr als 2400 Tote sind
zu beklagen und 100erte verschüttete
werden noch unter den Trümmern
befürchtet Kriegszustand in Israel mit
über 600 Toten auf israelischer Seite
und mindestens 370 Toten im Gazastreifen
nach dem
überraschungsterrorangriff der Hamas
gestern versucht Israel die Lage in den
Griff zu bekommen und die vielen Geiseln
zu befreien unter den entführten sind
nach Angaben des Auswärtigen Amts wohl
auch deutsche dazu gleich mehr zunächst
zu den beiden Landtagswahlen hier mit
bitteren Ergebnissen für die Parteien
der Bundesregierung wir beginnen in
Bayern dort kann CSU Ministerpräsident
Markus Söder seine Koalition mit den
Freien Wählern fortsetzen muss aber
leichte Verluste hinnehmen die Freien
Wähler legen zwar zu aber zweitstärkste
Kraft in Bayern wird die AFD die FDP
fliegt aus dem Landtag in unserem
Wahlstudio in München hat Matthias
vornoff die neuesten Zahlen so sieht das
aus als Grundlage für alle weiteren
Diskussionen die neue Hochrechnung aus
Bayern 19 Uhr die CSU kommt demnach auf
30,5% mit sehr leichten Verlusten die
Grünen 15,5% verlieren etwas mehr die
Freien Wähler 14,2 mit zugewinnen die
AFD
15,7% wäre damit knapp im Moment
zweitstärkste Partei die SPD 8,5% mit
Verlusten und die FDP bei 3% sicher
nicht drin die kleinen Parteien 6,6
insgesamt wir schauen mal was das heißt
für die Sitzverteilung hier in Bayern
205 Sitze sind es derzeit kann sich noch
verändern im lau des Abends aber nicht
das Kräfteverhältnis der Parteien
dadurch die CSU 83 grüne
35 Freie Wähler 32 AFD 36 und die SPD 19
Sitze wer könnte mit diesen Zahlen und
diesen Sitzen regieren CSU und Freie
Wähler das amtierende Bündnis in den
letzten Jahren 115 Sitze diese Linie
muss erreicht werden 103 das ist die
absolute Mehrheit reicht also dicke CSU
und Grüne schwarzgrün kommt auf 118 es
reicht sogar noch deutlicher und CSU und
SPD das würde wenn auch knapp nicht
reichen das ist mal der Stand der Dinge
in Bayern danke schön Matthias für den
Moment und die Reaktionen aus Bayern hat
jetzt Bettina Schausten ja so ist es wir
sind ja am Tisch versammeln und ich
beginne mit Markus Söder dem
Ministerpräsident von Bayern der das
auch bleiben kann jetzt haben wir schon
gehört Herr Söder ein stabiles Ergebnis
es ist aber eines das unter dem liegt
was Sie beim letzten mal eingefahren
haben also zufrieden können sie nicht
sein na warten wir mal wirklich noch mal
ab was der Wahlabend bringt aber Fakt
ist so wir sind in echt sehr turbulenten
und ernsten Zeiten und da war das
wichtigste was ich versprochen habe
Stabilität und Stärke in Bayern und es
ist nach der jetzigen Ergebnissen gut
möglich wir können eine bürgerliche
Regierungsarbeit fortsetzen ist ein
klarer Regierungsauftrag für die CSU als
Nummer eins auch ein klarer
Regierungsauftrag für mich persönlich
wenn man die Bewertungen auch des
Ministerpräsidenten nimmt und insofern
glaube ich ä ist es ein ein ein starker
Wählerauftrag zugegebenermaßen aber in
schweren Zeiten es ging uns auch nicht
um einen Schönheitspreis sondern darum
dass wir in dieser wenn man allein jetzt
denkt was gerade in Israel los ist was
uns bedroht braucht es auch eine
Regierung die den Bürgern Schutz
versprechen kann und es kann die bische
Staatsregierung weiterhin und das auch
zusammen mit den Freien Wählern ja wir
haben das vorher versprochen und haben
gesagt wir wollen die Arbeit zusammen
fortsetzen die war auch in den letzten F
Jahren sehr sehr gut und deswegen ist es
Ziel auch noch in dieser Woche Gespräche
von meiner Seite jedenfalls Gespräche
aufzunehmen um die Regierungsarbeit
fortzusetzen und Hubert eiwanger ist bei
uns Chef der Freien Wähler und
mutmaßlich auch künftig wieder
vizeministerpräsident von Bayern Herr
eiwanger was machen Sie jetzt mit dieser
neuen Stärke in den
Koalitionsverhandlungen die ja dann bald
beginnen ein Ministerium mehr also wir
gehen fair mit der Thematik um jetzt
schauen wir erstmal wie sind die
endgültigen Zahlen in Wirklichkeit es
hat sich ja immer noch erwiesen dass
sich etwas bewegt und wir sind natürlich
auch der Meinung wir wollen mit der CSU
gemeinsam weiter regieren um hier keine
Unklarheiten in Bayern aufkommen zu
lassen es gibt in vielen anderen
Bundesländern Konstellationen wo man
nicht mehr weiß wer soll mit wem
überhaupt regieren und die bundesampel
hat ja in den letzten Verhandlungen
gezeigt als die neue Ampel
zusammengekommen ist dass sie monatelang
verhandeln mussten bis das Land
überhaupt wusste wie es weitergeht wir
werden in Bayern innerhalb weniger Tage
klar Schiff machen und zeigen wir wissen
dass wir miteinander gut arbeiten können
Katharina Schulze die Spitzenkandidatin
der Grünen leichte Verluste bedeutet das
werden sie sich dennoch Herrn Söder
anbieten als Koalitionspartner erstmal
gratulation an die CSU Markus Söder zu
dem Wahlsieg für uns Grüne kann ich
sagen wir sind klar in Bayern verankert
wir werden das zweitbeste Ergebnis unser
Geschichte einfahren das macht mich
stolz und auch sehr dankbar und
selbstverständlich stehen wir als
DemokratInnen und Demokraten immer zu
Gespräche bereit ich glaube ein weiter
so kann sich Bayern einfach nicht
leisten wir haben große
Herausforderungen Klimaschutz Ausbau der
erneuerbaren Energien Stärkung unserer
Demokratie wichtiger denn je die müssen
angepackt werden die nächsten 5 Jahre zu
den Gewinnern des Abends gehört auch
Martin Böhm Spitzenkandidat der AFD hier
in Bayern die AFD wird in Bayern vom
Verfassungsschutz beobachtet eventuell
werden Sie zweitstärkste Kraft im
Landtag was machen sie damit also das
Ergebis was wir jetzt sehen und das
ganze ja noch ändern zeichnet uns als
zweitstärkste Kraft und damit vermutlich
als Oppositionsführer im 19 Bayerischen
Landtag aus jetzt hohe Verantwortung die
nehmen wir gerne an und ich muss doch
ganz verwundert feststellen dass die
eklatanten Verluste der Parteien die B
er gesprochen haben in einen siieg
umgemünzt werden die einzigen die
wirklich signifikant zulechen konnten
das sind wir mit 5% und da danke ich
allen den vielen Helferinnen Helfern die
diesen Wahlkampf für uns gut ermögl eine
Machtoption haben sie gleich wohl nicht
wir müssen keine Machtoption haben das
was wir heute gezeigt haben ist dass
eine Politik rechts der Mitte durchaus
starke Bewegungen bei den Bürgern
erzielen kann und wir schauen das schon
in die Zukunft schauen schon auf die
Bundestagswahl da werden die katten neu
gemischt diese ampelabrruppe in Berlin
abzulösen es gibt gute Mehrheiten rechts
der Mitte in Deutschland und da arbeiten
wir dran und da verstehen wir sag Martin
böm Spitzenkandidat der AFD ja Jubel bei
der AFD sehen wir wir schauen auch
schnell noch auf weitere Stimmen die
dieses
Abends es ist kurz nach 18 Uhr als die
AFD in Jubel ausbricht in der ersten
Prognose bestätigt sich was ich bereits
in den Umfragen angedeutet hat die
rechtsaußenpartei verbucht kräftige
Gewinne könnte gar zweitstärkste Kraft
werdenol diesem Land unsere bewerte
Demokratie zurück
Freunde Ratlosigkeit bei der SPD die
Sozialdemokraten weiter ein schatttenein
in Bayern führen sie verlieren noch
einmal und bleiben wohl im einstelligen
Bereich Erklärungsversuche das ist
offensichtlich dass wir es nicht
geschafft haben unsere landespolitischen
Themen für ein bezahlbares Bayern auf
die Straße genügend auf die Straße zu
bringen es ist alles überlagert worden
von der schwierigen Gesamtlage in der
wir sind die FDP in Schockstarre bis
zuletzt hatten die Liberalen noch auf
einen Stimmenzuwachs gehofft doch nun
sieht es so aus als würden sie aus dem
Landtag fliegen wie schon bei der
vorletzten Wahl
2013 heute ist kein Tag an dem wir
feiern heute ist ein trauriger Tag für
unsere Partei und ein trauriger Tag für
den Liberalismus in Bayern die FDP hat
ihr Wahlziel den ersten Wiedereinzug
seit 1978 in den Bayerischen Landtag zu
schaffen verfehlt und wir werden in den
nächsten 5 Jahren wieder mal
außerplamentarische Opposition in der
Landespolitik sein unangefochten vorne
bleibt die CSU allerdings zeichnet sich
ein äußerst schwaches Ergebnis ab eines
das zu dem schlechtesten seit 1950
werden
könnte gleich wohl ist die CSU recht
zufrieden sagt ein stabiles Ergebnis
letzte Frage an Markus Söder
prädestiniert sie das auch eine Rolle in
der kfrage der Union zu spielen können
Sie sich dazu noch mal motivieren also
da habe ich alles schon mehrfach vor der
Wahl gesagt es bleibt dabei ich habe
einen Regierungsauftrag für Bayern den
möchte ich auch erfüllen und ich glaube
auch so wie der Landtag zusammengesetzt
ist mit einer so starken AFD braucht es
auch einen sehr starken
Ministerpräsidenten in Bayern und dafür
bin ich da und alles andere kommt für
mit die in Frage ein richtiges nein war
das nicht doch ah okay dann halten wir
das jetzt an diesem Wahlabend auch noch
fest und geben damit jetzt hier aus
München mit Reaktionen auf das
Wahlergebnis Bayern zurück nach Mainz
Danke schön an die Runde aus Bayern und
wir schauen jetzt nach Hessen dort
bleibt die CD EU von Ministerpräsident
rein stärkste Kraft er kann sich
aussuchen mit wem er künftig regiert auf
Platz 2 auch hier die AFD vor den Grünen
die SPD mit bundesinnenministerin fäer
als Spitzenkandidatin schneidet
miserabel ab die Linke fliegt aus dem
Landtag und die FDP muss noch zittern
die aktuellen Zahlen aus Hessen hat
wieder
Matthias ja und hier sindind Sie die
neue Hochrechnung für Hessen 19:09 Uhr
demnach kommt die CDU auf
34,9% mit deutlichen Zugewinnen die
Grünen auf 15,4 mit Verlusten die SPD
mit ungefähr den gleichen Verlusten auf
ungefähr den gleichen Wert die AFD 16,7
wäre damit zweitstärkste Partei und
zugewinnen die FDP nach wie vor bei 5 %
und damit nicht sicher im Parlament
vertreten die Linke mit 3,5 nicht drin
die freien Wedler mit ebenfalls 3,5%
auch nicht alle anderen kleineren
Parteien zusammen
5,6%. sitzverteil im Wiesbadener Landtag
die seht demnach so aus 132 sitze
derzeit insgesamt die CDU 53 die Grünen
23 die SPD 23 die AFD 25 Sitze und die
FDP wenn sie denn die 5%de noch schafft
hätte acht Sitze für wen würde das zum
Regieren reichen CDU und Grüne
schwarzgrünen die haben bisher regiert
Ken auf 75 Sitze 67 braucht es das
reicht also CDU und SPD genauso und ein
Bündnis ein Dreierbündnis von grünen SPD
und FDP was es ja überhaupt nur geben
kann wenn die FDP drin ist das würde
selbst dann nicht reichen so viel die
Zahlen in Hessen danke schön Matthias
VOF was der Ministerpräsident und seine
Herausforderer zu diesen Zahlen sagen
das hören wir jetzt von Peter Wagner
guten Abend nach
Wiesbaden ja guten Abend Boris reinstt
nehmen mir die Union 7 8%pkte der
zugewonnen der Abwärtstrend ist gestoppt
was kann die bundescdu von der hessencdu
lernen heute ja es ist natürlich ein
schönes Ergebnis wenn sich so abzeichnet
bin natürlich sehr dankbar für das
Vertrauensbeweis der Wählerinnen und
Wähler das ist wirklich ganz großartig
ja und ist ein klarer Regierungsauftrag
für die häsische Union und ich glaube
die Grundlage und davon kann man lernen
ist wirklich Geschlossenheit und Freude
an der Gemeinsamkeit und das leben wir
in der häsischen Union und das ist auch
die Grundlage und die Voraussetzung für
ein solches Wahlergebnis Frau F ein so
schlecht vielleichtes Ergebnis hat die
hässische SPD noch nie erreicht sie
waren die Spitzenkandidaten datin gibt
es persönliche Konsequenzen was machen
Sie also erstmal möchte ich Herrn Rin
und der CDU in Hessen ganz herzlich zu
diesem Wahlergebnis gratulieren ein sehr
gutes Wahlergebnis deswegen meine
herzlichen Glückwünsche und ja es ist
ein sehr bitteres sehr schmerzhaftes
Ergebnis da gibt es überhaupt nichts
dran schön zu reden wir stehen als SPD
jetzt erstmal solidarisch zusammen wir
werden das Wahlergebnis auswerten und
ich ich bin natürlich enttäuscht dass
wir mit unseren Themen mit kostenfreier
Kita Gebühren mit Bildung mit
bezahlbaren wohnen und auch mit der
Frage nach zukunftssicheren Jobs nicht
durchdringen konnten in diesem Wahlkampf
sie gehen ja zurück nach Berlin haben
sie gesagt bleiben sie hessische
Vorsitzende der SPD das werden wir sehen
in den nächsten Tagen und Wochen unsere
Partei steht sehr solidarisch zusammen
ich habe es gerade gesagt wir waren
gerade zusammen bei unseren
wahlkämpfenden die wirklich einen
großartigen Job gemacht haben und ich
glaube es zeichnet uns als SPD aus
gerade in Krisenzeiten zusammenzustehen
wir gewinnen gemeinsam aber verlieren
auch gemeinsam herrud die AFD ist die
zweitstärkste Kraft geworden nun will
aber dennoch keiner mit Ihnen
zusammenarbeiten was heißt das für die
künftige Arbeit in der Opposition es
heißt erst einmal dass das ein
atemberaubendes Ergebnis ist das ist das
beste Ergebnis der AFD in
Westdeutschland jemals viele Menschen
haben zum ersten Mal AFD gewählt das ist
eine enorme Vertrauensvorschuss und
dieses Vertrauen gilt es die nächsten 5
Jahre zu erfüllen Dank Herr alvasir sie
wollten ja eigentlich Ministerpräsident
werden und hat in der Wind aus Berlin
heftig ins Gesicht geblassen
was müssen eigentlich die Grünen im Bund
lernen aus dieser Niederlage die es ja
nun wirklich ist also klar wir hätten
uns ein besseres Ergebnis gewünscht
deswegen Glückwunsch an Boris rin er hat
diese Wahl gewonnen sehr klar wir haben
immerhin unser zweit bestes Ergebnis das
es jemals gab erzielt aber es stimmt
alle Parteien die im Bund regieren
hatten kein Rückenwind mussten Berg
aufkämpfen das sieht man auch an den
entsprechenden Ergebnissen und wenn ich
das noch mal sagen darf für mich als
Lehrer auch aus dieser Wahl ist dass wir
einer Haltung von Vernunft brauchen und
gemeinsamer Problemlösung weil ich will
mich nicht damit abfinden dass dieser
blaue Balken so hoch gestiegen ist und
wir müssen gemeinsam daran arbeiten
Probleme zu lösen und zwar in einer
Haltung das Problem Lösens und nicht des
wechselseitig aufeinander Einschlagens
Herr rein mit wem wollen Sie Probleme
lösen in Zukunft sie können sich die
Koalitionspartner aussuchen na jetzt
kommt erstmal drauf an in
Sondierungsgesprächen miteinander
Schnittmengen zu finden und
Schnittmengen zu suchen und dann ist es
natürlich für uns wichtig so viel CDU
wie möglich umzusetzen aber das wird
jetzt die Zeit ergeben und die Gespräche
ergeben wir werden diese Gespräche allen
anbieten dem grünen Koalitionspartner
der SPD und auch der FDP vielen Dank und
damit zurück nach Wiesbaden zu Barbara
hallweg nach Mainz zu Barbara hallwieg
ins Heute stud Danke schön an die Runde
aus Hessen
wir haben es gehört das Ergebnis dieser
Landtagswahlen muss der Bundesregierung
in Berlin zu denken geben die SPD hat
angekündigt nenn sie Feser trotz ihres
schlechten Abschneidens in Hessen als
bundesinnenministerin zu halten die
Union sieht sich bestärkt die AFD feiert
Reaktionen aus Berlin es ist kein Tag
zum feiern wir sehen das mit Blick auf
Israel war eben noch mit friedich Merz
auch beim Brandenburger Tor das nimmt
ein schon mit stellt vieles in den
Schatten trotzdem klar das Ergebnis ist
sensationell der Boris rin hat einen
sensationellen Wahlkampf gemacht
fehlerfrei klare Themen Fokussierung und
die CDU Hessen war geschlossen genauso
muss es sein insofern Glückwunsch nach
Hessen ein bitterer Abend in beiden
Bundesländern die Ergebnisse haben sehr
komplexe
Ursachen die sicherlich nicht in ein
paar kurzen Sätzen zusammenzufassen sind
aber wir sind natürlich nicht taub und
blind sondern wir sehen dass die drei
Parteien der Ampelkoalition in beiden
Bundesländern verloren haben und wir
sollten die Signale alle miteinander in
der Ampelkoalition erkennen in diesen
Wahlergebnissen liegt auch eine
Botschaft für uns ich glaube als grüne
können wir sagen dass wir zwei stabile
Ergebnisse haben wir haben zweimal das
historisch zweitbeste Ergebnis in
unserer Geschichte in Bayern noch die
Chance auf Platz 2 zu kommen das heißt
wir haben gezeigt dass wir im ganzen
Land verankert sind und das ist eine
gute Basis die Ergebnisse setzen sich
natürlich zusammen vor allen Dingen
unsers dass wir über die Jahre immer
mehr Menschen von unserer freiheitlichen
Politik überzeugt konnten Punkt 1 Punkt
2 kommt hier ein Sondereffekt dazu dass
das natürlich eine denkzettelwahl für
die ampelregierung gewesen ist wir
merken das vor dem Hintergrund im
Augenblick der vielen Themen die die
Menschen beschäftigen doch Stabilität
ein wichtiger Faktor war wir sehen
natürlich auch dass das
Regierungshandeln in Berlin sich auf die
Landtagswahl niederschlägt weil ja alle
drei Partner auch hier in Hessen haben
ein Bußen hinnehmen müssen die Umfragen
haben es in den letzten Tagen ja bereits
angedeutet und es wird auch durch die
ersten Prognosen bestätigt der
rechtsdruck ist nun auch im Westen der
Republik mit voller Wucht angekommen die
Wahlen in Bayern und in Hessen markieren
damit auch das Scheitern der Ampel und
ihrer
Politik jetzt zum anderen großen Thema
dieses Sonntags nach Israel wir werden
die Verstecke der Hamas in Trümmer legen
droht Ministerpräsident Netanyahu am Tag
nach dem terroristischen Großangriff der
radikalislamistischen Hamas versucht
Israel die Lage unter Kontrolle zu
bekommen die Zahl der Toten auf
israelischer Seite ist mittlerweile auf
mehr als 700 gestiegen bei den
Gegenschlägen im Gazastreifen starben
bislang mindestens 370 Menschen Volker
dutsek
berichtet der Krieg war schon lange
nicht mehr so nah das hier ist Tel Aviv
und die Angriffe der Hamas haben auch
hier deutliche Spuren hinter die
Menschen wurden von dem Großangriff der
Palästinenser überrascht viele haben
sich zwar unverletzt gerettet doch der
Schock die Verunsicherung bleiben in
vielen Teilen des Landes wo seit gestern
mehr als 3200 Raketen und
Artilleriegeschosse eingeschlagen sein
sollen alle vertrauten auf den
vielbeschworenen Abwehrschirm und jetzt
das wo ist die Armee die Regierung wo
sind all die Sicherheitsfaktoren die das
israelische Volk an jedem Ort schützen
müssen Anges dessen was hier in Israel
geschieht hier herrscht Chaos es gibt
immer noch Terroristen in der
Stadt Israels Antwort auf die Angriffe
kam promt Bomben auf gazastadt und den
Gazastreifen viele Tote noch mehr
Verletzte am Mittag erklärt das
israelische Sicherheitskabinett den
Kriegs und Notzustand eine Maßnahme die
Ministerpräsident netanyah das Recht
gibt umfassende Maßnahmen zu ergreifen
viele Beobachter halten eine
Bodenoffensive nicht für
ausgeschlossen die Sorge im Westen über
eine Ausweitung des Konflikts wird
größer denn Israel nimmt am Morgen auch
die Hisbollah milit ins Visier die
proiranische schiitenorganisation hatte
vom Norden vom Libanon aus auf
israelisches Gebiet
geschossen schon am zweiten Kriegstag
spitzt sich die humanitäre Lage zu auch
im
Gazastreifen nach Angaben der Vereinten
Nationen haben bereits 20.000
Palästinenser in Schulen Zuflucht
gesucht Michael bewerunge ist nördlich
von sterot in unmittelbarer Nähe des
Gazastreifens michael hat Israel die
Gebiete rund um den Gazastreifen wieder
unter
Kontrolle also ich stehe hier direkt an
einem an einer Sammelstelle für
verletzte und am Nachmittag hatte ich
aber die Gelegenheit mich für ein paar
Stunden ins stot selber umzuschauen das
gleicht einer Geisterstadt keine
Menschen auf der Straße die sind immer
noch verängstigt zu Hause in ihren
Bunkern vom gestrigen Massaker Soldaten
durchkämmen die Stadt und wie wenig sie
tatsächlich noch die Kontrolle haben wir
haben es gehört in einem oton hier sind
immer noch Terroristen das haben wir
selbst gemerkt als wir ein Interview
geführt haben und vielleicht 50 100 m
entfernt es auf einmal zu einem
Feuergefecht kam also von Kontrolle in
dieser Region um Gaza kann noch nicht
die Rede sein auch noch nicht in den
anderen Ort und insot ist heute Abend
wieder eine komplette Ausgangssperre
verhängt worden der israelische
Ministerpräsident erwartet einen langen
und schwierigen Krieg israel hat den
Kriegszustand ausgerufen was bedeutet
das also alle Zeichen deuten auf einen
langanhaltenden Bodenkrieg hin eben auch
einen Krieg am Boden und möglicherweise
gleich an zwei frunden denn wenn Israel
in den Gasastreifen einmarschieren wird
dann wird das möglicherweise die
libanesische hzbollah im Norden
verleiten Israel in einen zwei
frontenkrieg zu treiben israelische
Behörden sagen sie sind auf alles
vorbereitet der Generalstab heute hat
heute mehrere hunderttaus Reservisten
einberufen in der an der Grenze im Süden
zum Gazastreifen und im Norden werden
Ortschaften evakuiert wir selber haben
hier ins derort einen erheblichen
Truppenaufmarsch beobachten können
gepanzerte Fahrzeuge Artillerie die
feuerter ununterbrochen das kann man
immer wieder hören schon jetzt in den
Gazastreifen was natürlich noch ein
großes Problem aus militärischer Sicht
darstellt wenn die Israelis in den
Gazastreifen einmarschieren dann ist das
Leben der hundert verschleppten Geiseln
dort unmittelbar gefährdet und deswegen
laufen momentan die Bemühung zumindest
die Älteren die Frauen und Kinder auf
dem Verhandlungswege freiubkommen das
wird aber nicht mit allen Geiseln
gelingen aber das wird Israel auch nicht
von einer Bodenoffensive letztendlich
abhalten
Michael beberunge live aus Israel vielen
Dank für diese
Informationen mehr als 100 Menschen so
schätzt die israelische Regierung sind
von den hamaskämpfern nach Gaza
verschleppt worden unter ihnen eben auch
Frauen Kinder Ausländer David römhilt
über die quälende Situation der
Angehörigen die Ungewissheit ist kaum
auszuhalten am Flughafen bengurion in
Tel Aviv eine Infostelle haben Polizei
und
hiererichtet die Menschen hoffen etwas
über ihre Angehörigen zu erfahren
bringen deren Kleidungsstücke mit für
dnapren mkowski ist gekommen um ihre
Mutter als vermisst zu
melden sie und ihr Ehemann und die
Nachbarn wurden von der Hamas entführt
vermutlich sind sie in Gaza ich hoffe
sie behandeln sie gut ich hoffe das
wirklich
sehr auch von einem Musik festival
unweit des Gazastreifens verschleppt die
Hamas gestern bei Reh offenbar mehrere
Menschen dieses Video soll die junge
israelen no agamani und ihren Freund
zeigen ebenfalls unter den entführten
wohl auch eine 22-jährige deutsche
Staatsbürgerin Shani Log ihre Mutter
stammt aus Ravensburg und bittet um
Hilfe man hat uns ein Video zugeschickt
wo ich eindeutig unsere Tochter erkennen
konnte bewusstlos im Auto mit den
Palästinensern und wie sie den
Gazastreifen abgefahren sind ich bitte
jede Hilfe oder jede
Neuigkeiten bitte zu uns schicken vielen
Dank unklar ist immer noch wie viele
Menschen genau von den hamasangreifern
als Geiseln genommen wurden israel hat
nun Ägypten um Hilfe gebeten sich für
die Sicherheit der Geiseln
einzusetzen Bundeskanzler Scholz hat
Israel die Solidarität Deutschlands
zugesichert er betonte auch man
akzeptiere es nicht wenn die Zitat
abscheulichen Attacken gegen Israel hier
gefeiert würden gestern Abend hat die
Polizei eine nicht genehmigte
proalästinensische Demonstration in
Berlin Neuköln aufgelöst es gab
Auseinandersetzungen vor dem
Brandenburger Tor in Berlin bekündeten
heute rund 2000 Menschen ihre
Solidarität mit
Israel dramatisch ist auch die Lage der
Menschen in Afghanistan dort stieg nach
den starken Erdbeben gestern die Zahl
der Toten deutlich an mehr als
2400 Opfer melden die Regierenden
Taliban hunderte Menschen seien in der
Provinz herad unter ihren Häusern
begraben Helfer suchen teils mit bloßen
Händen in den Trümmern in der Hoffnung
noch Überlebende zu finden sowie dieses
kleine Mädchen die Region war gestern
von mehreren Beben mit Stärken bis 6,3
erschüttert
worden jetzt ein harter Schnitt zu einer
erfreulichen meldung vom Sport Lukas
Dauser hat bei der turnwm in Antwerpen
am Barren die Goldmedaille gewonnen er
ist der erste deutsche Turner mit WM
Gold seit Fabian hamböchen vor 16
Jahren und jetzt noch die
Wetteraussichten im Norden und Osten
zeitweise Regen im Südwesten freundlich
die Höchsttemperatur liegt zwischen 12°
an der Havel und
28° am
oberrehein so viel von uns um 19:35
sendet das ZDF ein Spezial zur Lage in
Israel danke für Ihr Interesse alles
Gute Ihnen hier geht's jetzt weiter mit
unserem Wahlstudio und btin Schausten